So Donald Trump very recently pardoned his
convicted former national security adviser,
Michael Flynn, and Flynn is already out
there calling for Donald Trump to execute
a military coup to retain control of the White
House beyond January 20th, despite the fact that
it's very uncontroversially true that Joe
Biden won the 20 20 presidential election
and things have become so debased that this story
is barely making headlines. This is the story of
a former top national security official who has
been convicted and then pardoned by the president
for crimes related to protecting that president,
who immediately after being pardoned is out saying
declare martial law and effect a military coup
to retain power. Michael Flynn endorsed a call
on Twitter for Trump to go absolutely dictatorial.
This is a call from a group called The People the
We the People Convention, which says Donald Trump
should invoke martial law and just have a new
election. Didn't like the results of the first one
will do a new one. Martial law is when you impose
military control over functions normally handled
by civilian government. It's typically something
that is done only in extreme emergencies,
like really extenuating circumstances. Not
he lost and he wanted to win. You lost and you
wanted to win is not a circumstance in which
you invoke martial law. Now, really, we have to
understand how dangerous this arc is. Michael
Flynn commits crimes in his role as incoming
and actual Trump national security adviser.
He's investigated. Trump fires him, seems
to understand that Trump that Flynn did the
things he's accused of doing. Flynn cooperates
with the FBI, sort of is convicted, but Robert
Mueller recommends no jail time. Michael Flynn
then recants part of his cooperating testimony.
Then Trump pardons Flynn, whose crimes are related
to protecting Trump himself. And within days,
Michael Flynn, former national security adviser,
endorses the idea of Donald Trump declaring
martial law and holding a new election willy nilly
because he didn't like the results of the election
that we had. Once again, colloquially speaking,
what Michael Flynn is doing is sedition. Sedition
is conductor speech, inciting people to rebel
against the authority of a state or monarch.
That's what this former national security adviser
is calling for here. Fresh off of a pardon
for crimes related to protecting Donald
Trump, pardoned by Donald Trump himself,
the guy pardoned by Trump for crimes meant
to protect Trump is calling for Trump
to use the military to stay in power
despite having lost the election.
Understand how absurd that is. Every individual
by. Oh, and there's another layer to this.
The day before yesterday, Trump's press secretary,
Kayleigh McEnany, when she was asked about pardons
and with whether Trump would pardon Giuliani
or his children, as he's reportedly considering
Caylee said The only pardon I can
talk about is the one that happened
for three star general Michael Flynn. Now,
there's something interesting there. When
when someone serves in the military, they take an
oath and that oath doesn't expire. When you leave
active service, you take an oath when you
enter the military to defend the Constitution
of the United States against all
enemies, foreign and domestic.
The veterans oath doesn't expire. And so on every
level, it's particularly ridiculous that Michael
Flynn is out there saying invoke martial law,
take it, make a new election because you lost.
But the really crazy part is they want us to
believe they are the patriotic ones by doing this,
even though what they are doing is the opposite
of real but more properly and sensibly defined
patriotism. They are advocating for the opposite
of patriotism. They are they are part of the
domestic threats that they are as members of the
military, supposed to be protecting us against.
They believe and certainly claim that they
are the patriotic ones by doing this. This
national nightmare has gone on way too
long. We're down to six and a half weeks,
but who knows what they have planned even after
Joe Biden is inaugurated? Scary to think abou